[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale il est
télévisions locales vous présente
le club des territoires
et avec nous pour ce club comme tous les
lundis frère bonjour Yves merci d'être
avec nous directs
est avec nous bonjour
il s'est dit prêt pour 2027 alors est-il
le candidat naturel de son camp les
républicains seront-ils en mesure
d'avoir un candidat à la présidentielle
vous en débattrez si le robot qui est
cherche à rassembler son camp Alex la
nupel continue de se diviser oui le
torchon continue de brûler entre Fabien
Roussel le leader des communistes et son
homologue des insoumis Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
[Musique]
et l'actualité dans nos régions en
Bretagne aujourd'hui chez vous Alex là
alors que le gouvernement a présenté la
semaine dernière son plan pour lutter
contre le harcèlement scolaire le lycée
Saint Yves à bande-de-bretagne on
Ille-et-Vilaine a opté pour une semaine
d'intégration un peu particulière
natachaastord pour TV Rennes
apprendre la danse urbaine dans un
collège lycée professionnel et privé
mais surtout apprendre à connaître les
autres élèves de l'établissement je m'y
attendais pas ces grands stylé genre
franchement je suis stressée mais d'un
côté non parce que je me dis on connaît
la Corée du coup faut rester concentré
on va gérer c'est sûr qu'on connaît pas
et du coup on parle on peut les
apprendre à les connaître
tu as pas besoin d'être aussi allongé
cette chorégraphie est le fruit de 5
jours de travail encadré par les
professionnels de l'association Art
tempo
c'est hyper intéressant parce qu'on part
de zéro et en fait faut commencer par
apprendre à se connaître ça fait
vachement d'émotion parce que quand on
les voit à la fin on se dit bah on a
monté un truc super et tous ensemble
pendant cette semaine d'intégration
obligatoire aucun cours classique que
des activités artistiques auxquelles
plus personne ne vient à reculons
théâtre chorale K-pop et même rap sont
au programme du spectacle avec pour
thème commun la tolérance l'amour et la
paix
d'écrire ce qu'on ressent de dire ce
qu'on ressent de faire passer une
émotion ça me plaît beaucoup mais il y
en a qui n'ont pas l'habitude d'aborder
ce qui ressent de dire ce qu'ils ont
vécu et un petit coup de pouce de
solidarité et ils ont réussi à se livrer
pour la deuxième année l'établissement
privé qu'onfectionne ce spectacle une
manière de lutter contre le harcèlement
scolaire jusqu'aux vacances de Noël on a
eu beaucoup moins de problèmes entre les
élèves ça c'est estomper un petit peu
pour être vraiment très honnête à partir
du mois de janvier mais c'est la raison
pour laquelle cette année on va faire
notre tremplin des talents au mois de
janvier avec une réplique en avril qui
permettra de maintenir cette ambiance
que nous avons là pendant cette semaine
les élèves de la quatrième à la
terminale joueront devant 600 personnes
ce jeudi soir à 20h30
et voilà pour ce sujet de nos
partenaires de tvren on va passer au
débat politique de ce club on commence
par la droite Laurent Wauquiez est sorti
de son silence hier lors de la rentrée
des jeunes républicains il a fait un pas
de plus vers une candidature à la
présidentielle Jonathan du priez
un mot à peine couvert Laurent Wauquiez
fait un pas de plus vers l'élection
présidentielle de 2027 lors d'un
discours de 40 minutes devant les jeunes
et l’air à Valence le président de la
Région Auvergne Rhône-Alpes a cherché à
montrer sa détermination pour le scrutin
et lisez dans quatre ans j'ai mesuré ce
qu'il en coûte de sérénité et de
détermination pour déverrouiller la
République française
et aujourd'hui j'y suis prêt sur une
ligne de crête Laurent Wauquiez n'a pas
officiellement déclaré sa candidature
pour la présidentielle mais en partant
de loin l'ancien ministre de Nicolas
Sarkozy espère tuer le match à droite
alors certains cadres du parti tempère
quelques peu ses ardeurs
et encore une fois je l'ai dit et je le
répète faut pas mettre la charrue avant
les bœufs il va y avoir les européennes
ça sera pour nous une élection
importante dangereuse sans doute mais
très importante aussi pour les Français
je pense que Laurent est un de nos plus
beaux talents voilà simplement vous
savez la route est longue côté
macroniste on tente de décrédibiliser
une éventuelle candidature Wauquiez
alors qu'il prévoit de sortir sa région
du zan une mesure pour endiguer la
bétonisation des sols d'ici à 2050
Olivier Véran lui a rappelé qu'il ne
pouvait pas se soustraire à la loi
président de région je prétends
peut-être j'aspire demain peut-être être
président de la République et au moment
où je vous annonce ça en fait je vous
dis que je vais pas respecter la loi
voilà parce qu'elle ne me plaît pas
formidable
pas la loi j'espère effectivement qu'il
y aura des sanctions ou une autre
manière d'appliquer la loi localement à
Valence Laurent Wauquiez a aussi pris le
soin de mentionner aucun de ses
adversaires potentiels pour 2027 sans
toutefois au maître de critiquer des
clones d'Emmanuel Macron en creux
l'ancien président des républicains
visaient Édouard Philippe Bruno Le Maire
ou encore Gérald Darmanin
il est sorti du silence est-ce qu'il est
le candidat naturel à droite
je sais pas ce que ça veut dire un
candidat naturel vous êtes né pour être
bon je sais qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
pensent d'être le plus jeune âge et qui
continue à y penser quand il sera sous
les matins mais bon c'est sûr que bon il
a cette ambition là c'est une ambition
qui paraît
assez légitime de sa part d'ailleurs
parce que c'est un bel esprit c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup je dirais
travailler qui est particulièrement
affûté intelligent bon mais à mon avis
la concurrence va être forte et il y
aura beaucoup de monde je reste persuadé
que vous suivez on est dans une une un
paysage politique qui est divisé en
trois aujourd'hui vous avez la gauche
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ceux qui
contestent le leadership vous avez la
droite avec Marine Le Pen et ceux qui
peuvent lui constater aussi le
leadership et puis vous avez un axe
central sur le dans lequel vous pouvez
avoir
8 9 10 candidats finalement de Bernard
Cazeneuve
alors en Wauquiez en passant par Édouard
Philippe Gérald Darmanin et là ça va
être à mon avis c'est là que ça va se
jouer parce que s'il n'arrive pas
à dégager si cet axe central ne dégage
pas un candidat qui écrase le match
mais il va donc avant de parler
d'énergie
ça veut dire que vous avez Marine Le Pen
qui sera ou qui sera largement élu et
peut-être un deuxième tour Le Pen ne
Mélenchon on va revenir évidemment sur
l'élargissement est-ce que déjà il peut
s'imposer comme le candidat de son
[Musique]
campagne il a effectivement hier démarré
sa campagne je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord mais ça va être un débat qui va
être intéressant dans les mois les
semaines et les mois années à venir
c'est justement cette tripartition et
effectivement la gauche d'un côté
l'espace de centre droit de l'autre et
puis l'espace des nationalistes de
l'extrême droite et vous semblez mettre
Laurent Wauquiez dans cet espace centrif
centriste centrale de la vie politique
je trouve que justement il a fait un
choix assez assez fort
Laurent Wauquiez c'était justement de
décentrer son positionnement pour aller
du côté de l'extrême droite et
d'ailleurs c'est pas étonnant qu'il soit
allé chez les jeunes faire sa rentrée
politique parce que les jeunes sont les
artisans justement de l'Union des
droites et qui vont de la droite
radicale à une partie la jambe droite
Marion Maréchal-Le Pen etc donc c'est
pas étonnant qu'il soit allé puis je
note aussi quand même qu'il a pas
suscité un grand enthousiasme parmi ses
collègues des républicains sur la
quinzaine de parlementaires de la région
Rhône-Alpes Auvergne on peut pas dire
qu'il y a eu beaucoup de personnalités
qui sont avec qui se sont présentés le
patron des députés républicains de la
semaine nationale n'était pas là il
avait un empêchement personnel
visiblement bon on peut pas dire qu'il
suscite un grand intérêt encore à ce
stade Laurent Wauquiez on peut aussi se
dire que beaucoup lui reprochent de
l'avoir été absent d'un grand débat qui
a été quand même un débat structurant de
ces derniers mois qui a été celui de la
réforme des retraites on l'a pas entendu
sur ce sujet là on sait très bien que
son électorat était pas franchement
favorable à l'idée d'aller repousser de
manière toujours plus l'âge de départ de
la retraite qui est une de ses
propositions s'il devait être candidat
un jour on sait que ça a toujours été le
choix de la droite donc je je sais pas
s'il sera le candidat naturel de la
droite moi je ma conviction je le dis
souvent ici c'est que les républicains
s'ils doivent se repenser s'ils doivent
se repenser dans des espaces politiques
qui est celui de l'après Emmanuel Macron
c'est dans une forme de pour la peine
centralité presque une droite
républicaine un peu sociale qui était
celle de Jacques Chirac que la droite
pourrait repenser mais c'est
certainement pas en allant chercher des
voix chez Marine Le Pen j'ai toujours
pensé que quand la gauche va sur le
terrain de Marine Le Pen c'est pas
jamais la gauche arrivera à chercher des
voies de ce côté là et c'est pareil pour
la droite la droite n'a pas vocation à
tirer son son logiciel idéologique sur
l'extrême droite le cartel électoral de
Marine Le Pen il est déjà acquis donc il
reviendra pas du côté de la droite donc
je pense que c'est pas le créneau de
Laurent Wauquiez qui ramènera
ce que ce qu'on était l'histoire des
républicains à une forme de de de
mouvement politique qui pèsera dans les
années à venir non mais je pense pas
qu'il aille sur la droite moi pas du
tout je pense que ok il est pas fou il
sait très bien que
si il va sur ce terrain là
les gens ils préfèrent ils préfèrent
l'original à la copie il le sait très
bien ça donc ce qu'il veut faire et ce
que je cherche à faire justement je
pense tous ces gens qui imaginent
s'imaginent à l'avenir au centre de chez
qui politique c'est une espèce de grand
mouvement populaire
néogolien d'une certaine façon pour
employer des grands mots
derrière Macron et comme Macron ne peut
pas se représenter je pense qu'ils ont
tous en tête le fait que ils peuvent
avoir une chance dans ce domaine-là en
faisant mieux que Macron c'est à dire
que sur le plan économique
poursuivre finalement les réformes et
l'état d'esprit dans lequel il a mis la
France mais que sur le plan régalien
puisque c'est là où ça pêche et bien il
faut être un peu plus ferme mais c'est
du gaullisme c'est ce que faisait Pasqua
c'est ce que faisait
Chirac première version c'est ce que
faisait la droite dans les années à la
fin du 20e siècle en fait oui vous
demander
s'il était le candidat naturel
finalement mais en réalité c'est
véritablement le candidat naturel pour
moi il sera issu du macronisme
c'est-à-dire que Emmanuel Macron laisse
un héritage d'un gouvernement de deux
quinquennats qui auront été dirigés
ça va dépendre du choix des LR dans les
semaines et les mois à venir c'était
intéressant j'ai beaucoup de désaccord
avec Rachid t mal que vous aviez invité
tout à l'heure mais là pour la peine il
avait dit quelque chose d'intéressant
Gérard Larcher va jouer un rôle
important les sénateurs républicains au
cours de cette mandature vont jouer un
rôle important on voit bien
qu'effectivement il peut y avoir et je
pense que tout le monde a compris que
les LR étaient franchement compatibles
avec le macronisme mais que il joue un
rôle à l'Assemblée nationale de
d'opposant fort à Emmanuel Macron et au
Sénat on sent qu'il y a quelque chose de
différent qui se met en place donc pour
moi le candidat naturel de la droite il
sera dans ce qui auront été jusque dans
les premiers et derniers soutien
d'Emmanuel Macron et le tout ce qui sera
en dehors de ça je vois pas très bien
comment tout ça va exister et puis la
question c'est de savoir est-ce que
Laurent Wauquiez crois encore dans son
parti républicains pour gagner la
présidentielle en 2027 car on peut dire
que il ne fait pas tout justement pour
s'attirer les soutiens au sein de son
parti vous en parliez pierre il y a une
cassure c'est la réforme des retraites
si on se souvient en novembre 2022 quand
Éric Ciotti est élu à la tête du parti
des républicains justement il base sa
campagne son élection sur un ticket avec
évoqué comme candidat naturel en 2027 et
puis arrive la réforme des retraites ou
le robot qui est bien soutien cette
réforme et ce report de l'âge à 64 ans
vraiment du bout des lèvres il est très
silencieux et il laisse ericciotique
tout seul dans la panade dans cette
alliance se deal avec Emmanuel Macron et
voilà et à ce moment il y a une cassure
et au sein du parti LR il n'est plus
devenu il n'était plus le candidat
naturel partie républicain le parti
républicain il est mort mais il est déjà
mort il sera devant déjeuner là mais oui
mais bon je pense que ça ça sert
d'enceinte ça sert de cadre mais
l'histoire de du candidat du du centre
de ce pôle central plutôt
qui est très large ça sera hors partie
si ces cases là ça sera pas à
l'intérieur du parti socialiste si c'est
ok ça sera pas à l'intérieur du parti
républicain ou alors si c'est le cas bah
ils vont au casse-pipe ça c'est sûr non
non il faut qu'il faut qu'ils arrivent à
embrasser ça je suis d'accord
le macronisme enfin tout le macronisme
le berrouillisme le shiraquisme le
néogolisme enfin il faut qu'il
c'est ce que la droite d'une certaine
façon a perdu la droite républicaine et
c'est ce que la gauche dite de
gouvernement a perdu aussi donc il faut
qu'ils aillent au-delà le candidat
naturel de la droite juste pour répondre
à la question parce que j'ai fait des
circonvolutions tout à l'heure il est il
s'appelle Gabriel Attal il s'appelle
Gérald Darmanin il s'appelle
ce seront les héritiers du macronisme
justement candidat naturel de la droite
on regarde c'est le baromètre de ça pour
public Senna et la presse régionale on
le voit effectivement Laurent Wauquiez
il est très très loin derrière des
candidats potentiels de la droite a
commencé par Édouard Philippe est-ce
qu'il paye sa stratégie non mais
attendez tout ça va se mettre en place
après les européennes je pense que là on
est quand même on vient de passer
l'élection présidentielle c'était un peu
plus d'un an je pense que les Européens
vont
de son parti est-ce que ça peut être un
concurrent sérieux qui est à la tête de
l'Association des maires de France on le
rappelle un inconvénient enfin il pense
avoir un inconvénient c'est ce que
l'inconvénient qu'on lui colle à la peau
c'est le fait qu'il soit pas très connu
nationalement que ça reste un maire de
ville moyenne
est-ce que c'est est-ce que c'est un
handicap je sais pas regarder Emmanuel
Macron était inconnu du bataillon au
bataillon quand il s'est déclaré donc
faut voir je pense que tout ça c'est une
question de volonté une question
d'organisation de la part des uns et des
autres est-ce que l'islain a une chance
je pense qu'il a une voix qui peut
compter qui peut compter parce que il a
une approche différente c'est justement
il renouvelle un peu le style les snar
il est pas très classique dans son style
et il peut avoir une réflexion qui
apporte au débat et qui peut le
distinguer de d'autres par exemple il me
semble-t-il peut-être beaucoup plus
original que le robot qui est
je sais pas moi quand je les entends en
fait je vais j'écoute beaucoup avec
beaucoup d'attention les sorties de
David Lisnard parce qu'effectivement on
lui prête des intentions plus
importantes que celles de ses fonctions
de merde aujourd'hui mais quand
j'entends monsieur lismart et Monsieur
veau qui est Monsieur ok hier disait
dans son dans son propos qui faisait le
constat des échecs des politiques
successives de quinquennat en
quinquennat de la droite comme de la
gauche et pourtant quand j'entends le
discours qui sont les leurs aujourd'hui
et là où je me suis pas d'accord tout à
fait c'est que je vois pas très bien la
distinction c'est que on est toujours
plus de il faut réduire la dette il faut
limiter les dépenses publiques le
logiciel de la droite beaucoup moins
d'immigration je vois pas les nouveautés
dans le discours de Monsieur Wauquiez
alors même qu'il dit et Monsieur Lisnard
de la même manière parce que Monsieur
dit Smart on entend effectivement il
avait une position je trouve un peu
équilibrée et là compte tenu du contexte
de la pression migrade enfin pression
migratoire je déteste le terme pardon
mais en cause ce que la droite appelle
la pression migratoire parce qu'il y a
pas de pression migratoire en réalité ou
même la question de la dette publique
qui sont les deux créneaux un peu de
les deux créneaux idéologiques de la
droite ils sont dans le même discours ça
ils font un constat d'échec mais ils
disent il faut aller encore plus loin
bon bah pardon mais il sait pas
véritablement un renouvellement du
renouvellement je trouve pas qu'il y a
beaucoup d'originalité à dire s'il
demande arrive au pouvoir on baisse les
dépenses publiques on supprime les
effectifs de la fonction publique et on
ferme les frontières parce que ça suffit
d'immigration je vois pas très bien
l'originalité ouais justement est-ce que
le test ce sera les européennes est-ce
que les républicains ont un espace dans
ces européennes entre une liste
macroniste et les listes portées
respectivement par Jordan Bardella et
Mario maréchal c'est sur l'Europe que ce
sont fracassés à la fois la droite
républicaine qu'elle s'appelle UMP
RPR je sais pas quoi et le Parti
socialiste ça a été toujours leur
dilemme principal
c'est toujours divisé sur l'Europe et la
droite c'est toujours divisé sur
l'Europe entre ceux qui sont plutôt
pro-européens sans être fédéraliste mais
pro-européen et ceux qui sont
dès qu'il y a un problème c'est toujours
de la faute de l'Europe et qui donc
manifeste en ce sens leur entier
européanisme donc c'est tout le dilemet
mais ce dilemme là il est pas il est pas
réglé hein il est pas il est pas réglé
du tout
c'est intéressant ça va être intéressant
de voir comment comment ils envisage ça
mais il est sûr que si ils n'ont pas de
députés européens la prochaine élection
c'est pour moi de 5 % ce qui était le
cas à la présidentielle alors là c'est
la fin des haricots oui très rapidement
il faut faire attention je trouve à la
manière dont on présente les choses
c'est-à-dire que je trouve qu'il y a une
évolution notable dans le paysage
politique c'est que plus personne veut
sortir du nom européenne en tout cas de
manière affirmée plus personne y compris
d'ailleurs l'extrême droite en tout cas
de Marine Le Pen ne souhaite pas la
sortie de la France de l'Union
européenne en revanche il y a des
projets différents il y a des projets
différents qui s'affirment quand on dit
un tel ou une telle serait anti-européen
non il propose des voies différentes on
dit que la France insoumise une partie
de la gauche serait anti-Europe non il
propose des voix alternatives à ce que
devrait être une autre union européenne
je pense que il faut faire attention
c'est pas les anti-européens il faut
entendre qu'il y a des projets
différents qui s'affront pour une autre
union européenne la gauche va dire il
faut une Europe plus sociale plus
équilibrée sur le plan géopolitique et
de la sécurité la droite va dire
évidemment toujours la même chose il
faut renforcer la coopération européenne
sur la question de la sécurité de la
défense etc donc je vais dire il y a pas
des je trouve c'est une évolution
notable quand même de ce paysage
politique français c'est qu'il y a plus
d'anti-européens il y a des gens qui
veulent une autre Europe ouais je suis
pas tout à fait sûr de ça moi je pense
que il y a une Europe qui se construit
et qui qui se construit sur des bases
qui sont pas toujours bonnes qui sont
trop bureaucratiques qui sont trop mais
ceux qui ont un discours où ils veulent
refaire l'Europe c'est généralement un
discours où ils veulent casser et casser
un élan commun c'est c'est généralement
pour reprendre aller une bonne dose de
nationalisme mais ce qui est pas un mot
péjoratif mais c'est justement pour
reprendre leurs droits
l'Europe ça divise aussi à gauche mais
pas que Alex on peut dire que les
divisions se creusent au sein de la
nuque oui rien ne va plus dans
l'alliance entre les parties de gauche
qui a été conclu il y a un an et demi
autour de la France insoumise avec une
joue de verbale qui se poursuit entre
Fabien Roussel le patron du Parti
communiste français et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon le leader de la France
insoumise alors on le rappelle que
depuis quelques jours les insoumis
justifient la comparaison entre Fabien
Roussel et Jacques Doriot qui était un
collaborationniste et regardez ce que a
dit Fabien Roussel ce week-end il était
invité de France 2 c'était samedi soir
je le cite en 2027 je souhaite que la
gauche gagne et elle ne gagnera pas avec
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il faut qu'on puisse
se permettre d'avoir une gauche qui soit
certainement différente de celle que la
France insoumise défend je pense qu'il y
a de la place pour avoir une gauche
républicaine laïque universaliste voilà
le message de responsable communiste
alméride d'être clair et forcément et
bien la réponse des insoumis ne s'est
pas fait attendre dimanche matin chez
nos confrères d'Europe le coordinateur
de LFI manuel Bompard estimait que
ces propos est bien avaient acté le
départ de Fabien Roussel de la nupes
tout en rappelant que l'intéressé
n'avait fait que 2% à la dernière
présidentielle en 2022 alors que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait fait 22% et
d'ailleurs Jean-Luc Mélenchon a lui
aussi réagi à cette nouvelle sortie de
Fabien Roussel c'était hier soir chez
nos confrères de LCI écoutez
il y a un grand malaise à gauche avec
certaines déclarations celle qui dans
les discours de Fabien Roussel pose
problème à gauche par exemple un exemple
par exemple dénoncer la gauche de la
sistana par exemple lorsque la tête de
liste la France des élections
des meilleurs quand la tête de liste aux
élections européennes que Monsieur
Roussel a nommé dit mieux vaut la
retraite à 64 ans que le droit à la
paresse c'est-à-dire mettant mieux vaut
travailler plus dur et mourir au travail
qu'un texte du genre de Karl Marx à une
époque où il y avait ni retraite ni
week-end ni vacances voilà Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui est cité Léon des
fontaines le tête de liste des
communistes aux élections européennes et
parmi les Antilles à Roussel il y a
aussi la social escargot de l'Alga qui
organisé ce week-end ses rencontres de
la gauche Abraham dans l'Aude et oui
c'est ça brame une petite commune de
l'Aude la présidente de la région
Occitanie et des régions de France à
rassembler différents responsables
politiques de la gauche pour échanger
sur l'école la laïcité ou les migrations
parmi eux on pouvait citer Bernard
Cazeneuve Nicolas Mayer Rossignol le
maire de Rouen qui porte la ligne
anti-ups au sein du Parti socialiste ou
encore Yann Brossat le nouveau sénateur
communiste et puis également le Parti
radical de gauche des personnalités de
gauche qui avaient tous un point commun
et bien leur hostilité à la France
insoumise et à la nups et Carol Delga
dans son discours lors de ses rencontres
de la gauche a critiquer je cite la
gauche de l'invective la gauche hostile
dans une allusion à peine voilée à la
France insoumise
la nuque se voulait incarner l'Union
aujourd'hui on parle plus de division
est-ce que c'est clairement d'échec j'ai
l'impression tout ça c'est beaucoup du
théâtre quand même écouter franchement
il y a un an les formations de gauche
qui sont aujourd'hui
en discussion plus que houleuse on
signale un accord de gouvernement ils
ont même signé un accord pour que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon ça leur premier
ministre avec un accord de gouvernement
sur près de 600 propositions et on nous
expliquerait aujourd'hui que cette
gauche là n'est pas capable de gouverner
ensemble n'est pas d'accord sur
l'essentiel de ce qui fait cet accord
tout ça est du théâtre on voit très bien
que Monsieur Roussel est engagé dans une
course à et il a plutôt bien réussi à
redonner une forme de fierté au
communisme ça a été ça a été une
réussite de sa part en prenant des
positions un peu divergentes de celles
de ces petits camarades de la France
insoumise et puis il faut l'assumer il
le dit il le dit pas il dit pas je serai
candidat en 2027 mais il le dit il dit
je veux que les Français et le choix
donc ça veut dire que oui il sera sans
doute il sera sans doute cavalier seul
en 2027 face soit une pluralité d'autres
candidats soit à un candidat unique de
la gauche et des écologistes comme le
veulent l'ensemble
aujourd'hui des formations politiques
que ce soit les socialistes que ce soit
les écologistes ou que ce soit les
heures soumis tout le monde a dit qu'il
fallait une candidature unique de la
gauche et des écologistes donc bon à
partir de là il va falloir un moment
donné que les uns les autres soient un
peu plus raisonnable dans leur prononcer
énoncer médiatique et que il se
remettent un peu à discuter à discuter
du fond c'est ce que font les jeunes
d'ailleurs les jeunes de la souplesse
les jeunes de la nuit Pesse écologistes
insoumis et socialiste se sont mis
d'accord sur un programme de un
programme un programme pour les
élections européennes c'est bien la
preuve qu'à priori il y a quand même
plus de choses qui rassemble cette
famille là politique que de choses qui
divisent ils sont d'ailleurs reçus je
crois aujourd'hui par les différentes
têtes de parties politiques pour voir si
tout ça peut être convergent pour des
listes unitaires aux élections
européennes mais ce que l'on entend
entre Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Fabien
Roussel désespèrent considérablement les
lectorat de gauche et c'est pour ça que
je dis c'est du théâtre auquel on veut
encore tenir quand on voit autant
d'invectives
au pouvoir et être majoritaire elle est
condamnée à s'entendre de Fabien Roussel
à Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce sera pas
possible autrement on peut pas faire 100
je veux bien que madame delgas monsieur
une manière Rossignol ou monsieur
Roussel décide que la France insoumise
on les met hors-jeu mais on peut pas
gros construire la gauche sans la
principale force de gauche c'est pas
possible on peut pas reconstruire la
gauche sur la France insoumise entre la
gauche sans Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce que
ce qui vit c'est plus Jean-Luc Mélenchon
que la France insoumise il y a deux
considérations à mon avis d'une part ils
ont tous la chance d'être dans
l'opposition et donc dans l'opposition
bah Vous vous opposez c'est leur métier
ils s'oppose il s'oppose tous
à Macron donc dans l'esprit du public
aujourd'hui c'est Macron ou pas Macron
que ça soit d'ailleurs à gauche que à
droite pareil si vous prenez
les nationalistes c'est Zemmour Le Pen
ils s'oppose voilà il s'opposent et ça
gomme un peu leur différence aux uns et
aux autres ça c'est la deuxième chose
après la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est un débat de fond qui a
raison stratégiquement qui a raison
je vais vous étonner celui qui a raison
c'est Mélenchon
je pense que l'avenir de la gauche c'est
pas l'avenir c'est pas la gauche que
défend qui fait d'ailleurs très plaisir
à la droite c'est pas la gauche que les
fins Roussels qui est une gauche du Lab
laborieux du travail
républicaine
c'est pas cette gauche là c'est la
gauche des minorités c'est la gauche du
wokiisme c'est la gauche qui est en
train de c'est cette gauche là qui est
aujourd'hui c'est la gauche des
banlieues c'est la gauche
des quartiers populaires de banlieue et
des communes
et électoralement qui a beaucoup plus de
chance que la gauche de Monsieur Roussel
qu'il n'existe pas en fait qui n'existe
plus
c'est ça les sujets parce que cette
gauche là elle est partie où elle est
partie chez Madame chez Marine Le Pen et
donc monsieur Roussel il peut avoir
attiré la sympathie et il est
sympathique d'ailleurs beau gosse tout
ce que vous voulez mais il a pas de
troupes il est c'est trop elles sont
partis puis bien longtemps c'est vrai
qu'il y a quelque chose d'assez étonnant
mais bon je vais me faire des amis en
disant ça mais c'est vrai que la contenu
des débats qu'on entend depuis quelques
jours ou même monsieur Roussel nous
expliquer qui peut être le candidat du
second tour et gagner face à Laurent
Wauquiez pas Laurent Wauquiez à face à
Édouard Philippe en 2027 on en oublie
quand même que il a fait deux un peu
plus de 2% Fabien Roussel et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon plus de 20% mais je je il y a
un débat à gauche chien des bas qui
traversent à gauche et qui va falloir un
moment donné régler les communistes et
je trouve que la réflexion est justifiée
parce que c'est aussi l'histoire du
Parti communiste qui veut que
les communistes centre leur position
politique sur la question sociale et
Fabien Roussel explique très bien qu'une
partie de la gauche
je sais trop peut entêté ou occupé des
questions sociétales la question des
droits des LGBT la question des droits
des exilés la question du féminisme
l'écologie et c'est un débat qui clique
à gauche c'est vrai que la question
intersectionnelle qui est une partie qui
occupe une grande partie de la gauche ne
fait pas un point d'accord avec la
gauche de Monsieur brossa ou de Monsieur
Roussel donc c'est un débat qui va
falloir trancher mais enfin et encore
que je suis pas sûr que ce soit un débat
si enfin je veux dire ça c'est pas ça
qui va empêcher la gauche demain de se
remettre d'accord je le dis et je le
redis ils sont condamnés à son temps de
ce que je veux dire c'est il y a un an
ils se sont mis d'accord sur plus de 600
propositions pour changer la vie des
gens on peut pas dire que demain ils
seront pas capables de se remettre
d'accord sur à peu près les mêmes types
de proposition c'est impensable ils sont
en train de désespérer les lecteurs à
populaire l'électorats de gauche et même
au-delà se remettre d'accord avec les
fractures qu'il y a aujourd'hui
c'est à eux d'en faire la démonstration
encore une fois qui seront les arbitres
oui mais surtout c'est eux d'en faire la
démonstration je quand je dis tout ça et
du théâtre je pense que Monsieur Roussel
et Monsieur Mélenchon mais là pour la
peine c'est quand même Rousset il
attaque du côté de la France insoumise
donc il y a il y a un agresseur et un
agressé pour la peine c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui qui fait les frais de de
la tournée médiatique de de Monsieur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon je bon c'est une
erreur monumentale que Sofia est relayé
cette ce propos qui était et qui a été
écrit par nos confrères qui est Daniel
Schneiderman qui a écrit effectivement
un papier qui s'en est expliqué
d'ailleurs ils comparent pas enfin de la
Roussel à Dorio la France insoumise n'a
jamais dit que Fabien Roussel = Dorio
Jean-Luc Mélenchon le premier Sofia
elle-même dit qu'elle avait jamais
comparé la Fabien Roussel à Dreux elle a
juste ils ont juste dit qu'il y avait
des positions de Monsieur Roussel qui
était problématique et qui pose des
questions là pour la peine sur un cake
sur des sur des termes d'accord
politique sur la question migratoire sur
la question de la France des allocations
sur la question de de la souveraineté
nationale il y a des points de désaccord
ça c'est une certitude mais il y a pas
eu de comparaison de Fabien Roussel avec
Dorian on aura l'occasion de reparler de
tout ça faut qu'on laisse la place à
Alex pour sa revue de presse régionale
[Musique]
Alex on commence par la Dépêche du Midi
puisque Emmanuel Macron est dans le
Lot-et-Garonne il va annoncer la
création de 200 brigades de gendarmerie
effectivement le président de la
République va concrétiser une promesse
de campagne la création de 200 nouvelles
brigades de gendarmerie sur le
territoire pour lutter notamment contre
la délinquance en milieu rural un effort
historique qui comprend la création de
plus de 2000 postes de gendarmes et
parmi ces 200 brigades il y aura des
brigades mobiles dans l'objectif et de
décentraliser la gendarmerie dans les
villages le handicap à l'école c'est la
ligne du Télégramme et oui les
accompagnants des élèves en situation de
handicap les aesh sont appelés à faire
grève demain pour dénoncer leurs
conditions de travail une aesh qui fait
ce métier depuis 10 ans témoigne de son
désarroi aujourd'hui dans les colonnes
du télégramme à cause de problèmes
d'effectifs et bien il explique que de
plus en plus d'élèves en situation de
handicap se retrouvent sans accompagnant
et souffre dans des classes étroites et
surchargées je la cite les aesh cours
partout et n'ont pas le temps de créer
un rapport de confiance avec ses élèves
le tout pour installer au niveau du SMIC
en pleine crise de l'immobilier les
mères peuvent désormais taxer les
logements vides et oui c'est à la une de
la Charente Libre à Caen en Charente et
bien le taux de logement vacants atteint
à 10% c'est au-dessus de la moyenne
nationale et dans le contexte de fortes
tensions locative et bien les communes
pour inciter les propriétaires à réagir
et décide de taxer à ces logements vides
ces maisons sont souvent délabrées
abandonnés depuis des années les mères
sont obligées de passer par les services
des impôts pour retrouver les
propriétaires et l'objectif pour ces
élus c'est aussi d'attirer de nouveaux
habitants alors qu'ils n'ont pas
forcément de foncier disponibles pour
construire à quelques jours du match de
Coupe du monde de rugby France-Italie le
Dauphiné Libéré fait le portrait du
phénomène de la sélection italienne ange
capozo il a 24 ans c'est un petit
Tellier d'un mètre 77 qui multiplie les
essais pour la sélection italienne et il
est français et oui c'est un enfant de
Grenoble sa famille d'origine italienne
élevée dans l'agglomération grenobloise
au Pont de Claix il a joué au club de
rugby de Grenoble le FC Grenoble pendant
quelques années en Pro D2 et
parallèlement et bien la sélection
italienne elle l'a appelée et il a
accepté mais il prend à cette sélection
très au sérieux ce n'est pas du folklore
il y a un vrai sentiment d'appartenance
donc voilà c'est le plus français des
Italiens qui va affronter les Bleus
vendredi à Lyon on a quand même pour les
ponts on est quand même pour les deux
merci merci Alex on regarde vos une la
France face à l'explosion des demandes
d'asile celle avec du Figaro oui alors
là c'est factuel c'est le nombre de
demandeurs
qui a beaucoup augmenté et pour des
raisons qui paraissent tout à fait
évidentes c'est alors il y a beaucoup de
de bandes qui viennent d'Afghanistan
puisque bon on reprend le pouvoir et on
va ça dans le Figaro pierre on revoit la
une on en a déjà parlé c'est un appel au
président de la République
une trentaine de témoignages de famille
et de victimes de violences policières
qui interprèm le président de la
République et je redis aussi un très
grand entretien avec l'intellectuel
camerounais Achille BMB sur les rapports
France Afrique et passionnants merci
beaucoup
merci Alex merci à tous de nous avoir
suivis prochain rendez-vous à 18h Thomas
Hugh et vous suivrez à partir de 14h30
élection président du Sénat très bonne
journée à demain
[Musique]